high in the hills of Oaxaca State South
Mexico the community of San Pablo juila
thought a Revolution was coming
2017 cannabis was legalized in Mexico
for medicinal use here they've always
grown at Farmer oligario tells me that
illegally
before we had to do it in secret and it
was very risky because the soldiers came
to destroy the crops they thought that
with the government's decree things
would change they began refining their
crops to meet the requirements for legal
medical cannabis but the communities run
into a big problem that legalization
happened under the last Administration
now they say the current one simply
won't issue them licenses
we feel offended we put all our effort
into this and the government hasn't done
its part they've asked us for a lot of
permissions and forms and we've done it
all and they haven't fulfilled their
side of the bargain
they're currently grown with personal
consumption permits many producers in
Oaxaca are poor mainly indigenous state
are in the same position more have
applied here for commercial permits than
anywhere else in the country Daniel
Ramirez an agro engineering grower has
lobbied the government to provide the
licenses he thinks he knows why it won't
it's a plant that's been vilified a
taboo our president doesn't want to be
remembered as the one who liberated
cannabis use in Mexico
we reached out to the Mexican Government
for coming they didn't want to talk
meanwhile in Oaxaca Villages like
wheeler are waiting this community's got
big plans when they're finally allowed
to commercialize their cannabis
greenhouses of a thousand square meters
for each producer and a chance to build
the local economy so that there are more
jobs here right now a lot of people from
this Village have to head to the United
States to look for work so there's a lot
of State for them possibly for Mexican
patients too some doctors believe
cannabis could help with anything from
cancer relief to epilepsy people in
Wheeler have been using the plant
medically for Generations whether
they'll get the chance to do so
commercially is a question for this
government John Holman Al Jazeera
wheeler
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera